uh-uh what are those Donald oh [ __ ] bro
[ __ ] Donald O'Connor yo do you know what
dude they what do bro yeah man
radar they what about Oakland okay
that's it bro okay bro bye see you next
week yeah
Oakland bro yo do yo but for real dude
shut up
I love you I mean yo do we haven't
handled out of Chicanos on the show
Mexicans we had al Madrigal but he
doesn't count really does it count
I don't know but he doesn't look like
he's married to Karina one he's like a
nerd Hispanic right
they still Mexican I don't know because
he penetrates Asian you know me he's
like it is ambiguous ly Mexican okay
very good comic now and but we haven't
had a full-blood one in ever really be
honest hey we got one today well let me
introduce everyone in the room first up
we got George god George you know what I
I made a mistake of that [ __ ] George
is a pink dick because whenever I'm
onstage now somebody yells it out I was
in the audience
George has a pink dick and then I had to
explain to the crowd that who he is and
I don't like doing that but oh we got my
[ __ ] girlfriend here kalila and my
partner here we got here Guilbeau and
then we got a very special guest hazers
trail give him a round of applause real
bro I've been gonna say something right
now Oh what do I make fun of your look
do you make fun of my lay all the time
yeah that's great
cuz let me tell you something right now
man you don't look human at all brah
really I mean you're when you smile you
have little chiclet teeth yeah that has
nothing to do with your head and then
you see a lot of gums yeah yeah yeah
yeah I want to get sponsored by Ringley
[Laughter]
yeah and you look like remember back in
the 50s 40s circus these have those
pinheads
I know what the disease is you know you
kind of have half yuria of a pinhead
yeah no Bob be real like if you were in
like a circus in the 1950s in Mexico
City killing it
y'all might got the lives would be just
all around the corner you can have a
piece that even get in what I should
have went into that instead of comedy no
it begins the problem here's a great
thing about you dude not only do you
have a funny look you're a funny guy you
really are a funny guy you know how to
write a joke oh yeah you know who you
are but dude your face bro [ __ ] yeah
makes for real dude yeah I get it all
the time I mean oh no what do they say
yeah what do people say this is the best
roast joke I've ever heard
about me I was uh we're going back and
forth with Ian Edwards in the in Edward
said he's like tell me why do you have
the complexion of a hot black girl you
do yeah but it's like you can always
tell how happy I am by the gum tooties
ratio oh yeah you got a lot of gum dude
but I'm like a dog though the more wet
you see my gums yeah okay he's hydrated
see that's what I like because here's
the thing dude I look at myself in the
mirror right and I can make fun of
myself oh I've always been like that
I'm very self-deprecating I don't give
up I really don't give a [ __ ] what I
look like right when I was younger I did
when you know high school you're like
you look at the mirror go oh i don't
look like Brad Pitt it's never you know
you realize the amount of [ __ ] you're
gonna get throughout your life and it's
really depressing because when you're
ethnic you're living in America you're
weird-looking right you think you're uh
I'm not gonna I'm unfuckable well you
don't know that there are other ways hey
you get famous or whatever you mean yeah
the things I've done you know but my
point is is that but I'm like that too
so I know what I look like I like what
the way I love self-deprecating took me
a while to get into but I feel like
comedy is the only business it's like
look if you're a model you start losing
your hair careers over by over
in comedy it becomes an asset whatever
is wrong like my like I talked about my
[ __ ] up teeth I say that my bottom
teeth low like downtown LA from far away
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
this is Bank of America yeah like now I
can't fix it because I have a joke am i
fixing I lose my minutes yeah you know
whatever feel kind of like my comb-over
once it started falling off yeah oh I
literally shaved off 20 minutes remember
your oh yeah go got his teeth fixed
right yeah but one day he just showed up
with like just you know the mask teeth
or the movie the mask this is all right
yeah yeah this gigantic white early deer
you know I don't like that I like I like
real real you know what it's like I
remember reading this thing
ODB when he got money he got the grill
he didn't fix his teeth he put the like
grill over the [ __ ] up teeth I'm like
yeah I want to do that [ __ ] I want to
get a grill and just put it over my [ __ ]
yeah yeah I just don't keep it keep oh
thank you your teeth dude
[Music]